[Musik]
partystimmung aber nicht in einem club
sondern in einem zug die fahrt mit dem
kulturzug berlin breslau ist eine reise
der besonderen art nur am wochenende
gibt es diese direkte verbindung
zwischen den beiden städten 19 euro
kostet eine fahrt in viereinhalb stunden
kommen die fahrgäste nicht nur dem
zielort näher
sie können auch eine menge über die
deutsch-polnische vergangenheit erfahren
eine der organisatorinnen ist natalie
wassermann der berlinerin mit polnischen
eltern ist der austausch beider länder
wichtig und zwar nicht nur hautnah mit
den künstlern sondern auch miteinander
an bord gibt es ein kulturprogramm an
dem schon mehr als 300 künstler
mitgewirkt haben
diesmal tritt die kontrabassisten
michael hilbig auf die eine lesung
musikalisch untermalt eine rollende
bibliothek bietet den reisenden viel
lesestoff zur vergangenheit deutschlands
und polens
und eine dauerausstellung an den sitzen
zeigt lebenswege deutscher und
polnischer breslauer also ich denke dass
es sehr wichtig dass es diese verbindung
zwischen zwischen portsmouth in berlin
gibt
dadurch
gibt es möglichkeiten sich kulturell
auszutauschen
das ist ein sehr guter weg
die auch teilweise gemeinsame geschichte
zu bearbeiten besser verstehen und auch
die zukunft neu gestalten
das konzept kommt an viele hier sind auf
spurensuche holen spielt schon eine
gewisse rolle auch mit meiner familie
auch wenn wir jetzt keinen wirklich
wichtigen geografischen ursprung haben
also schon viele generationen aus der
name zurückliegt aber zumindest eine
gewisse nähe ohne zu wissen wie die nähe
eigentlich aussieht
von daher bin ich sehr interessiert
meiner großmutter ist in schlesien
geboren an der polnisch tschechischen
grenze und hat dort die ersten zehn
jahre gelebt und es dann eben nach
deutschland gekommen und deswegen weil
ich glaube noch nie selber auch die
coolen war war das auch ein grund für
mich in deutschland zu fördern zugucken
der kulturzug wurde 2016 ins leben
gerufen als breslau europäische
kulturhauptstadt war 2017 bekam er einen
kulturmarken award als trendmarke des
jahres autor wolf kampmann kälte oft
lesungen dieser zug ist ja nicht nur ein
zubringer wie andere züge also man setzt
sich nicht nur rein um von einer stadt
in die andere zu gelangen sondern um auf
die stadt eingestimmt zu werden
ankunft in breslau überall in der stadt
findet man spuren der deutschen
vergangenheit
seit ende des zweiten weltkriegs ist
breslau ein teil polens wolf kampmann
hat einen roman geschrieben der auf der
geschichte der stadt basiert
bis 1945 war bressler eine nur deutsche
stadt von 1946 bis in die 90er jahre war
es eine nur polnische stadt gewesen und
es ist relativ neu
das erst in den letzten jahren ein
bewusstsein dafür entstanden ist dass es
eine stadt mit einer deutschen und einer
polnischen geschichte ist und man es
jetzt als deutsch polnische stadt und
auch als begegnungsstätte von deutschen
und polen begreifen kann ohne das immer
gleich dieser revanchistische hinter
gedanke aufkommt wolf kampmann wird erst
am nächsten tag mit dem kultur zug nach
berlin zurück fahren
auf die gäste die sich jetzt schon auf
den weg machen wartet an bord eine
silent disco über kopfhörer bekommen sie
die musik direkt auf die ohren
[Musik]
im rhythmus vibrierende gürtel ersetzen
den bass form ist leichter für mich dass
die zukunft da ist sie spüre dass wir
offen sind und dass wir uns in die
richtige richtung bewegen und das macht
mich glücklich
ja wirklich alle hier vereint zu sehen
stimmt mich fröhlich mehr als 30.000
gäste haben den kulturzug schon genutzt
tatsächlich zog die leute näher
zueinander ohne komplikationen einfach
auf sein sehr sehr lebendigen
spielerischen ebene
doch nicht darum geht dass man sich als
nation begegnen sondern als menschen auf
dem auf der basis der kultur und auch
den basis auf der basis des austauschs
die organisatoren wollen das projekt auf
zusätzliche europäische verbindungen
ausweiten für mehr gegenseitiges
verständnis und ein offenes europa